greetings everyone
i'm sara domer i'm the director of yale
institute for global health
i'm really delighted to welcome you to
the yale institute for global health
conversation series
in addition to young institute for
global health which is also called ygh
we are indebted to the george herbert
walker junior lecture series and
international studies
at the macmillan center for
international and area studies
at yale focus sponsoring this event and
the series
today's conversation will be focused on
the impact of
kobit 19 pandemic on
higher education we'll cover different
aspects of it
but we will specifically discuss the
pandemic response strategies
taken by university presidents around
the world
we will also consider how the pandemic
has shaped the future of
higher education and so obviously there
we it was a
a little bit of a baptism of fire for
several institutions
it was uh challenges that institutions
faced
uh but a lot of these challenges come
opportunities and
changes uh for for the long term
um and so this is an opportunity to
touch base with uh three prominent
university leaders
uh to discuss some of those things that
will be different going forward
um it is my pleasure to have uh
therefore three distinguished guests to
join us today
all of whom are esteemed leaders in
higher education around the globe
uh peter salloway who's the president of
uh
yale university here in connecticut um
uh betsy bradley president of wesser
college in new york
and president firoz rasool um president
of the argo khan university
which is headquartered in karachi
pakistan but has campuses
in many parts of the world uh before
moving
to our question and discussion i will
introduce
each of our guests in a little bit more
detail
um peter salve is the
um the 23rd president of yale university
and a professor of psychology he has
held
several leadership positions at yale
since becoming president in 2013
he has led the development of new
programs and facilities
um you know strengthened partnerships
worldwide increased access to yale
college education which is uh um a
remarkable
um goal and achievement uh for
for a university and an enhanced
multi-disciplinary collaborations
and uh entrepreneurial opportunity for
faculty and students
uh during the covert 19 uh pandemic uh
president salve has been leading yale's
efforts to control the spare spread of
the virus and mitigates its impact
yale scientists and scholars are
conducting research on treatments
tests and vaccines for nova for this
virus and helping people understand the
science behind the public health
guidance
and collecting and analyzing data to
address issues like
unemployment and vaccine reluctance so
it's been a 360 degree response
for from a university that has uh
multiple areas of excellence
uh betsy bradley has served as the
president of vassar college since 2017.
in that time she has led uh the college
to establish
new programs and partnerships um in
india rwanda and
china to bring the model of liberal arts
higher education
to these settings and and in many parts
of the world
and most recently she served on new york
state's
reopening advisory committee and helped
draft the guidelines
for new york uh higher education
reopening
in the midst of the pandemic and so it
was
a pretty daunting task for university
leaders to figure out how to
you know accomplish uh their educational
and research missions and
and i think uh new york was lucky to
have someone with
um betsy's background as
a university leader as an educational
leader in the state
prior to coming to prior to becoming
the president of vassar uh president
bradley was on the faculty
at yale for more than 20 years she was
elected to the national academy of
medicine
in 2017 and is a member of the council
of foreign affairs
the third um esteemed guest is
president feroz rasool he has served as
the president of
uh the agahn university since 2006 under
his leadership
the university has grown geographically
but also
uh programmatically in terms of its
impact and diversity aku
which the arakan university is known
popularly as now operates
in kenya tanzania uganda pakistan
afghanistan and the uk
through its six campuses seven teaching
hospitals
300 and 300 outreach medical centers
treating more than 2 million people each
year
um ikea's teaching research and
healthcare has been transformative
and under his leadership during the
covet 19 pandemic
aku earned its position as
a trusted partner for to national
governments
for innovation in health and education
policies uh
emergency response and clinical trials
for vaccines and therapeutics
for example acu's hospitals were first
in pakistan and kenya
to treat a covet patient to offer
molecular testing and to administer
vaccines on behalf of governments
where eq is based so it's my pleasure to
welcome
all three of our guests i'll start the
first round
with a big picture uh question um
peter what was the biggest challenge you
faced
as a university president and and how
did you respond
well thank you assad and and uh it's a
pleasure to be here and a pleasure
to be with so many people today uh with
fellow presidents uh for rose and
and betsy uh uh uh really um
an honor for me uh and i think it's very
important to emphasize before i
answer the question that uh while i
uh maybe the president of yale uh the
team
working on our covid response
was enormous and committed
and assad for example was
on a call every morning at 7 00 a.m as
part of our health
our public health uh policy group
uh really helping us understand the data
and uh make campus policy on the basis
of science and
uh and data and many many many
uh pitched in uh our biggest challenge
in many ways i think is the challenge of
every
college and university uh president and
that is
to do two things a massive
pivot that required
a multi-faceted changes across the whole
university while not giving up
on the idea that we are going to
continue our mission
education and research primarily
so uh as we started to hear about the
novel coronavirus
uh last winter uh but before it came
to this country or or to our region we
were already
planning on how do we keep the elk
community
and our neighbors safe and i i have to
say
that is the single biggest challenge
right
how do we make sure that our university
doesn't become
a a vector for the disease in a way how
do we make sure
our local community is safe but that
we're not spreading this disease
through our host city and our region and
and beyond right it's enormous
responsibility
and then how do we continue education
and research
uh while doing so
so i would say the biggest challenge and
i'm
speaking at a pretty abstract level here
is
balancing these two objectives staying
safe
keeping the community safe keeping
ourselves from spreading the virus
beyond the walls of the campus while
fulfilling our responsibilities as a
major research university
and as a research university we knew
that we would need to rely on our
experts
our experts in public health our experts
in medicine in nursing
uh we knew that we'd get insights from
people in student affairs in housing and
dining
just give a couple of examples we knew
that we needed to
quickly put together the public health
policy group that i mentioned earlier
an emergency policy group to implement
recommendations from the health policy
group
and uh people people
all over the campus really responded so
within a couple of months well within uh
what uh uh a week and a half of sending
everyone home
essentially for spring break
we were able to um pivot to
substantially an online uh
learning environment this was thanks to
our faculty
uh who are willing to learn new skills
very quickly
and thanks to a great teaching and
learning center called the purvu center
who provided
coaching and technical assistance and
instruction
and very quickly we were able to reopen
laboratories
especially the ones doing research
relevant
to covid it's transmission it's
treatment it's prevention
but i would say perhaps the most
important
and this will be my final comment i'm
speaking a little too much at length
here
are our the most important common
component
to being able to stay committed to our
mission
making sure that we were teaching making
sure that our researchers were advancing
ways to fight coven 19
vaccinations treatments innovations and
patient care
the most important single thing
that happened on this campus so far
was that our students and others
adhered to the guidelines people wore
masks
people social distanced people stopped
gathering in groups
and that happened immediately and it has
been sustained
for 14 months the
the strongest warnings that we heard was
that
particularly students would not do that
and you could not trust your students to
do that and you were there there were
editorials being written that it was
unfair
for university presidents to put that
burden on students
undergraduates in particular or late
adolescent young adults they couldn't be
trusted to do this
and we made the decision that we were
going to trust our students to do this
to do the right things we're going to
make it as easy as we could for them to
do the right things that we were going
to
be as clear as we could communicating
what needed to be done
but at the end of the day we were going
to trust our students
i don't want to be president of a
university where i can't trust
our students to do the right thing and
i'm glad we did
it may have been the single most
important component of all this
to answer the question the part of this
that was the single most specific
challenge
and um i i'm just grateful and proud
that uh our students and our community
as a whole did the right thing and
continues to do the right things
in response to the threat of the virus
excellent before i go to the next
preschool i would remind that people
have the ability to
sort of ask questions that we will sort
of channel towards our speakers our
panelists
um in a while um uh you know after we
sort of
get through the first part of the
section a lot of you are following are
watching it on facebook live
and so there's a way uh to um
to send questions through that as well
um and so
uh appreciate everyone staying engaged
uh betsy you're
you you're leading an institution that
had
a few unique assets uh its location
it's you know student body and a
president who had a public health
background
any specific insights again in terms of
the big picture the biggest challenges
you've faced and
anything you you'd like to share that
that university leaders
uh can learn from your experience and
your unique
uh vintage point thank you saad i really
appreciate being invited and peter it
was so nice to imagine and think back to
what yale was like so congratulations to
everything
you've been able to accomplish in these
last treacherous 14 months
um just maybe a little bit of
orientation we have um
about 2500 undergraduates at vassar
a faculty of three to 400 300 people
about 1200 employees
and um we stayed open um through the
whole pandemic and still are so we have
about 85 percent of our students are on
campus taking classes in person
many faculty want to do some kind of
hybrid or there are students remote so
and we have a ton of tents around so
ultimately depending on the weather
the classes are 50 50 in person or not
remote um in the fall it was more like
70 in person when it was nice and sunny
and i'm hoping to see that again this
may
um so it's been quite a ride and i think
um
looking forward and looking back um the
question you had posed to us what
is the biggest challenge you know i
actually think they're a
couple that happened really early on the
first biggest challenge was to screw up
the courage
to say we're coming back and i remember
the exact senior team meeting
um when i could see a path towards how
we could actually house students
on campus and i was working with the new
york state so i knew it would be
you know by the guidelines but i
remember saying to people
look we have to decide now we're coming
back or we're not you can't decide that
in
a month and a half it has to be now and
we're gonna have to plan
every single minute for the next eight
weeks to be able to do this and
you know our team like said okay let's
do it so that was
really a moment and um and then i would
say the second thing that occurred is
very soon after that is um we set our
values
um we had a long meeting about what were
our values and our values ultimately
were
to protect the most vulnerable among us
no matter what we did
we were going to either the financially
vulnerable or the medically vulnerable
or maybe
isolation vulnerable socially vulnerable
that was job one
and our second value was equity
everything we did we tried to do
equitably so if we're gonna allow the
athletes to do this we had to allow the
rest of the non-athletes to do that in
other words
the context would be one where we could
be
as equitable as pr as possible and in
all of campus response
um and then like peter we said our third
value is our mission
we provide the highest quality liberal
arts education in an inclusive
and diverse setting and we're going to
keep that mission alive
um so setting those values ended up
being fundamental to everything we did
um and then i would say the largest
challenge which was similar to what
peter said was culture change
you know how do you get 2 500 students
to decide
yeah they're going to be not socializing
with each other the way they used to
not going to eat indoors with each other
for a while all of the various
pieces and and how do you calm down the
parents who are very nervous about the
fact you're going to do this
and that culture change really came
through a mechanism we called vassar
together which was about a 40-person
uh committee of faculty students staff
administrators
coming up with what would the guidelines
be and we tried to use harm reduction
what were guidelines we could live by
what were things we would
say um you know we can actually hold
everybody on this campus and if we do
that then maybe they don't need to be so
careful masking because they're not
getting exposed outside
once we know they're negative and
honestly that worked
it was uh and still works i mean even
now that we're
more vaccinated than we were we're
constantly looking back at these to say
um okay well can people go into town now
or
can our can our gather can we have class
inside at the normal density
all of those now go through um the
vassar together group
and if there is any sort of obligation
of the ex
expectations we also have a large group
called cct that actually re-educates
does restorative justice
does do some referral to student conduct
if they're issues so
those structural pieces that we put in i
think they were challenging
i guess the culture change was the
challenge and i think those structural
pieces really helped us
achieve it at least so far but look i'm
still learning from everyone else so
don't tell me to teach others i want to
hear what furrows and peter have to say
and learn from that so we can
continue to be healthy and safe great
wonderful
so feroz aq has this unique role in
multiple countries
um as the premier sort of healthcare
teaching institution and also as
increasingly in other fields as well and
especially in education and media etc
um any thoughts from that perspective
the biggest challenges that you faced as
a university
uh president and and how did you respond
thank you very much sad for this
invitation and it's fascinating
listening to peter and betsy to hear
their experiences in the last 14 months
as you pointed out we are in multiple
countries and the first thing that we
had to figure
out for each of our countries what the
government was doing
and remember our governments are all in
the developing world
and they initially were not sure about
whether they should lock down whether
they should
allow continued engagement or
interaction of people
and they were sending out signals on
what schools and universities should do
public transportation and and so on uh
lockdowns on shopping and other areas
and their lockdowns were much more
onerous than anything i think we've seen
in the us or in europe
and so we were trying to navigate our
way through that to say how do we
keep the institution going while we try
and work with
the rules and regulations from the local
governments
and even and even those rules were
changing almost by the week
as they were learning more as all of us
were learning more
so that was our first challenge in
trying to figure out
what we could and could not do in each
of the countries
borders were closed so we have you know
movement between countries was
was curtailed and that also affected our
faculty who used to
travel between campuses or within the
country
so that that was the first thing we had
to adjust to the second thing
that i would say that uh being as a as
an international university
is how do you now come up with a set of
common goals of values as we've heard
that we are going to adhere to and
practice
while complying with national
in multiple countries requirements and
so
that was a big challenge for us and we
had to figure out how to do that in one
way
i guess it was more by the invitation of
the government than by any
deliberate strategy by us was we
were appointed on all of the advisory uh
groups that each government had set up
to help them
make policy decisions through this
process so we had our faculty our
researchers our administrators
on several committees with governments
and so we were able to influence
shape or inform look if you do this then
this is the consequence if you do that
then maybe we can we can adjust this and
be more
flexible in some areas so that was the
second uh
challenge and i think the third for us
as a university
because we are a private not-for-profit
university in the developing world
most of our income that we support other
than tuition
comes from either donations uh or comes
from
the income of our hospital um the
seven hospitals that you mentioned
around the countries that
where we are and immediately what
happened was as kovit came about the
non-covid patients
disappeared they just evaporated and
that was our income and we would have to
figure out how are we going to keep
going
without the flow of uh funds coming in
from our hospitals and healthcare system
and that was a big shock to the whole
system and
i think peter used the word massive
pivot
i think massive is an understatement i
mean the pivot that we had to figure out
is how do we not only keep going with
the education side
but also how do we continue to run the
hospitals because people wanted
care they wanted to come for tests they
wanted to know whether
you know this fever they have or this
coal they have
is not something more serious and i
remember one day in karachi
our hospital was full the emergency was
full
and we had a group of 2000 people
outside trying to get into the hospital
and we had to get the police to stop the
people from rushing the campus
and the campus at the hospital is also
where our academic
facilities are so the students couldn't
go in and out people couldn't go in and
out
and this panic set in about uh you know
what's gonna happen to me
and of course it affected our staff and
it affected uh many of our
faculty and doctors and nurses who were
all trying to
provide so we were on the one hand
trying to teach
and keep that going on the other hand
trying to make sure that we kept
our facilities open for for those people
who needed care
and thirdly was trying to figure out
well how do we actually get some funds
out of this
uh and that was our biggest challenge
and it continues to be
although some of that is stabilized we
figured out how to separate
between our facilities our campuses our
hospitals
those patients that come for covid or
covid testing or kobe treatment
and those patients that come for
non-cova healthcare
and how we can continue to give them the
confidence that we will keep you safe
you will get treated for heart heart
disease or diabetes or
cancer whatever else you have and that
we will help you
continue to get recovery from your
disease and make sure you're not going
to be infected with covid
so for instance every patient that comes
in we test them for covis
just to make sure that they're not
carrying something asymptomatic
uh and then we you know we're dealing
with a different problem and so
we figured out a protocol a system where
we're able to do this and the last thing
i would say
before we open it up to questions is we
set up a global response team
we call it the grt we meet once a week
we used to meet once every two weeks
probably go back to once a week
depends on the we're on the third wave
in our countries right now
so we will have to adjust and the
biggest challenge that we're facing not
just the fact that we have increasing
number of patients
but what are we going to do about
vaccinations
you mentioned that we are one of the few
vaccine government vaccination sites
but you're talking about very few
vaccines because
most of the vaccines that come to the
countries where we are
will come from kovacs or this facility
gavi set up facility
and kovacs by gets all of its vaccines
from the serum institute of india
which is top shipping and we don't know
when it's going to resume so
the lack of vaccines in the countries
where we are is a massive problem it's a
huge problem
so for us going back to some sort of
normal or some
uh stability is still not on the cards
it's not in our
vision because we just cannot see when
our
students and others will be vaccinated
the best we've been able to do
is vaccinate some of our frontline
healthcare workers
but other than that this is an ongoing
challenge that we will face for the
foreseeable
future until we see some solution
to vaccinations for other countries
outside
the western world and we see solutions
that
we figure out how to live with covet in
all of its
different variants and manifestations
over the next period of time
i'll stop here now that's a really good
point you raised and if i may comment on
that as
someone who has spent most of his career
on vaccine research
i think we as a world will have to we
have to do
better in terms of getting the vaccines
out to countries where the outbreak is
not going to be over
in a few months the prospects of things
getting under control
for higher education for countries like
the us
uh are high um even with the variance
etc
but with the inequity in vaccine
distribution is going to impact
continue to impact higher education and
the broader society
going forward so i think as academics as
institutions and as students i know
there's a bunch of students
that usually sort of watch our our
events
in this conversation series it is our
responsibility to be advocates
and problem solvers with our partners in
low and middle income countries
uh switching to you know another sort of
round of questions
uh peter what changes have occurred um
that will strengthen the institutions
like yale moving forward
uh particularly you know how it engages
with the rest of the world
yeah thank you uh for that uh question
um you know first of all i would say
that our
uh world view has changed as a result of
covet
we more than ever recognize uh
that we have we are citizens of the
world and we have obligations
to the world you know once again
we uh uh what covet has done
is make the question of disparity
of inequity so salient to us
and i think we can all know that
intellectually but as the epidemic as
the pandemic
unfolded where who what communities were
affected
most severely what individuals
had the um most severe
outcomes and now as we have vaccine
where is the vaccine being distributed
where isn't it right
so we we as as institutions of higher
learning
we have to recognize that we can play a
role in
promoting uh inequalities
promoting disparities in in health or we
can play a role
where we're part of the solution and i
think going forward
we need to be thinking and i know most
people share this view in principle
but we need to be thinking about how uh
how to do that
how to uh reduce disparities in our own
society
and globally now you asked me the
question uh you know
what changes have occurred that would
strengthen institutions moving forward
particularly how they engage
in the world i think we have become much
more nimble as a result of dealing with
the pandemic
at working across boundaries and at
collaborating
right the value of collaboration has
never been clearer and that happens at
multiple levels
so um our administrative structures
uh find people no longer in their silos
no longer not talking to each other but
working with each other every day the
number of people who worked
who have been working for 14 months with
someone they didn't even know
prior to the pandemic is huge
right uh the number of faculty working
across
boundaries and disciplines right so the
people
modeling the epidemic working with those
developing vaccines
uh working uh with with economists about
how to
deliver vaccine right much more
integrated
uh uh approach to solving a problem
and of course a more global perspective
on how that
uh problem needs to be solved no one
person no institution no nation can
solve a crisis like this
on on its own i think the crisis has
really accelerated
our understanding of the need to
participate and engage
in multi-disciplinary teams and
international partnerships
it could be just one example it's a
small example
but it's important so since the start of
the pandemic
the results of thousands of not yet
published studies from around the world
relevant to covet 19
have been uh
generated right findings from thousands
and thousands of studies tens of
thousands probably
well how do we make sure there's a way
for everybody to
benefit from those
findings well yale partnered up with
cold spring harbor labs
and and um bmj actually
to create something called med archive
uh
and uh it's a pre-print server for
health related research
and uh you know this is a small
contribution
but it really allows scientists to share
data and insights
across boundaries of discipline across
boundaries
across national boundaries and it can
dramatically accelerate
uh the search for treatment uh the cert
clinical treatments the search for
vaccines and i think it's a good example
of how do we build networks platforms
ways of working across uh the world that
break down barriers that historically
have stood in the way
of uh pro progress i think universities
play a particular role
in uh their ability to convene their
ability to create
such platforms uh their their ability to
work
uh in a um less politicized context
than than our governments can uh
with others like-minded others around
the world
in addressing something like
a pandemic but other kinds of global uh
crises as well
i think i think that's a great point
going moving to moving on to
um betsy um so there's been so
i'll give you an audience question uh
there's a lot of discussion of keeping
campuses safe
at least in the u.s in fall through
vaccination
do you think requiring students and
that's the question from from one of the
audience members do you think requiring
students to be vaccinated will become a
norm
on college campuses at least in
countries where the vaccine is available
thanks for the question and i saw that
in the q a and nice to see you since i
know the person who asked
i think it's too early to tell that
certainly is our approach at vassar that
students will be required to be
vaccinated
however they will be able to opt out if
they have medical reasons or religious
reasons you know
there's always a path off but we'd like
to get ourselves to
you know 95 98 of our students are
vaccinated
and i think that that is um really an
important piece
and it ties very well to sort of this
larger
culture of we precedes me you know we've
worked on that hard advesser and
i do think at this time students get
that getting vaccinated is part of that
you know maybe
they're nervous about it uh but i think
at the end of the day
they're going to privilege their more
social environment
than their own individual view on that
we did in fact yesterday
have a clinic here and vaccinated 450
people so that was
really exciting um again working with
the state of new york and i hope that um
we'll be able to do that over the long
haul i just want to quickly say i
completely agree with betsy and
uh we we need to we need our students to
be vaccinated
we're going to uh we're working very
hard to get vaccine available to them
uh in an easy way and
it's probably too too early to answer
the mandatory question but i definitely
lean
in that direction quite strongly great
for that so i'm so glad as a vaccine uh
researcher um and then someone has
contributed a vaccine policy
i'm particularly happy to see a bunch of
vaccine related questions
so the next question is to firoze firoz
especially you know given uh sort of
aqu's role in policy etc
um how can you know
universities all across but uh
deal with misconceptions regarding
vaccines
uh um around the world uh
in countries where you work um and and
and how can institutions of higher
education
especially with a strong health
component
convince people that these vaccines are
safe and effective
this is another audience question as i
said yeah right
that's a the difficult question is i
think in any part of the world but
certainly for us vaccine
hesitancy or reluctance has been a
fact of life for many years now as
you're aware
all the different types of vaccinations
for children that
require have been a challenge for
countries like pakistan and east africa
polio vaccinations have been a big
challenge uh as
you know that pakistan is one of the few
countries that still has
cases of polio and the vaccinations
uh campaigns have been mostly successful
but not entirely successful
and the reasons vary from um
social political um
plan uh to
i i'm not sure i would agree that in our
countries there are religious reasons
there may be uh people who take
advantage of or
use religion as a reason for people not
to get vaccinated uh so the the issue of
vaccine
uh first for us it's availability as we
mentioned
once we have vaccine availability then
we hope that uh
you know we're able to vaccinate as many
people as possible
uh the challenge is going to be access
to remote areas where our populations
live
and then once you get to those remote
areas working with the clan leaders and
the tribal leaders
to have them agree that that village
will be vaccinated or not
and vaccinations have had a
history in parts of the world where we
work which will make it
i think a challenge that we are going to
have to work with governments work with
social groups work with uh village
communities
uh with civil society to be able to get
people
to become much more comfortable uh that
they will be able to
accept vaccines the the issue also as
you know
as a public health expert in the first
wave
and the second wave perhaps africa and
asia
were less affected if you look at the
rates and people said it was the
demography
much younger population it was innate
immunity
because they lived with pathogens all
the time i mean there were lots of
theories that were out there
so people have this sense that well it's
not going to affect me this is a disease
of the west
you know that's where it's happening
with those of us who live in the
developing world
are not really going to be as affected
as those elsewhere
but that's beginning to change if you
look at what's happening in india right
now and if you look at some of the
countries of africa
as well south africa being one kenya
which is where we are based
we can see a massive surge in the third
wave
and so obviously the something is
changing either the variants are
changing it
or some other factors are changing so
this
um smugness if you like about we don't
need the vaccines
is going to disappear very quickly so
it's a it's sort of a long answer to
your question but i think it's going to
take multiple inputs and multiple
players
and multiple factors to be able to
convince people to be vaccinated
great so the next question is peter i'll
ask you the question and others can
chime in
is from um from dean stanwell
uh who's the dean of for the for those
of you who don't know is the dean of uh
yale school of public health
is a a a very prominent public health
professional
and has contributed substantially to the
pandemic response
during this pandemic as well so he
obviously
his initial comment is that you know he
congratulates the university's
leaders for making their respective
communities safe
uh but but his question is that there
were a lot of parallel efforts
um that happened at each campus uh
is there a way uh to come up with
sops approaches that can be
shared across different universities at
least different classes of universities
different
categories of universities based on
their size location
and the composition of student body etc
so so maybe peter you can start and if
others want to chime in
that'd be great as well stan thank you
for that question
and i think uh there are informal
efforts to do that but i think the um
general goal of of trying to
uh write the case study and
develop the you know standard operating
procedures for the future
is a very very uh uh good one
um i i'm part of a few of the networks
that yale is a part of so the the ivy
league
presidents get together on a pretty
regular basis
and there's an incredible openness about
uh
sharing our experiences uh uh with covid
uh i the um aau which is a group of uh
university research universities it's uh
primarily us uh uh and uh
um that group gets together
uh and and talks among itself uh sharing
uh uh information uh so
i i think it'd be great to step back and
try to write a playbook
for for for the next time there
there's certain it's very interesting
right because there's certainly lots of
general principles
that we can develop i think one of them
is
um you know listening to experts
respecting science i'm thinking at the
most general level right listening to
experts respecting science
acting congruently with you know
for for us the guidance from the state
of connecticut guidance from the cdc
having said that there also is a lot of
local variability
betsy was giving the example they are in
a fairly rural
uh part of the state uh i mean there's a
there's an important town near them but
but careful well you know you have a you
have a
small city you have a small city and
then a larger rural catchment area i
guess i would say but
but every every you know every campus is
a little different is all i'm saying and
even when i talk to the ivy league
presidents what can be done let me not
make it so personal
you know what could be done at dartmouth
sitting in hanover new hampshire
was very different than what could be
done at columbia
sitting on the upper west side of
manhattan just to use
more more poignant examples or more more
obvious examples
so yes i think we can write the standard
operating procedures
and i think step one is going to be
listen to our experts listen to our
scientists respect the modelers
uh uh uh and the like uh but then
there is going to have to be some uh
variability across institutions too
great uh that's um you know i think i
think that's a
that's an important set of principles
for perhaps
you know other crises as well i guess uh
other than pandemics and so and so forth
um betsy you know switching to um
international collaborations uh you know
and
any thoughts on how covet pandemic has
played a role in connecting
universities around the world and and
how universities
can effectively and strategically create
learning networks so that's another
question
from our audience yeah and and i agree
with what um
peter had just said about local networks
being so important but let's take it to
the higher level what i've sort of
witnessed during this pandemic is the
and again this is very much reflective
of vassar and vassar's um
sort of deep commitment to the liberal
arts and multi-disciplinary thinking and
sort of critical thinking
what i've really noticed is uh
universities around the world
that are just dipping their toes into
what really is liberal arts and
particularly i'm thinking of
the university of global health equity
in rwanda
which i started working with when i was
at yale but we continued to at vassar
or the university of liberia these are
places that are really working to
develop a medical care system and a
health care system that can prevent
future pandemics
and what are they asking for they're
asking for some
courses that prepare people in the areas
of the liberal arts meaning critical
thinking humanities thinking about
it's not just the medical approach to
the vaccination and the dealing with
covet but the
um thinking more broadly about humanity
and how
his history can teach us how we might
want to
deal with these things in the future so
what i find
interesting is whether we will
ultimately have more international
collaborations
where we're trading what each other
knows
in the case of vassar i think we're very
well versed in the area of liberal arts
and
the pedagogy that goes with that and i
actually think that pandemic has shown
um how important those sort of
out-of-the-box thinking skills are
at the same time um you know as peter
said we're
in one place in new york and it also we
learn a lot from being engaged
internationally of what
what others may um may be prioritizing
etc so
i think it's opened up opportunities to
tell you the truth plus we're all used
to zoom now so
it's so much easier to have conferences
and just this
event you know was a tenth of the price
it normally would be to fly everybody in
and whatnot so
i think we're really um galvanizing that
kind of collaboration internationally
and it will amplify over time
wonderful um
aku played a role a very interesting
role
in quickly building capacity in
healthcare providers
in countries um where it works
so through for example uh building
capacity for critical care or sort of um
patients who require critical care even
when it's not available um
and and quickly upscaling um you know
scaling up
uh undergraduate education online etc so
any
interesting perspective of using these
online platforms
that can outlast the pandemic
that were built up fairly quickly both
in terms of the university's core
mission
but as its expanded mission to build
capacity in a crisis
especially in a situation where internet
access is not uniformly available
so two parts to your question so the
first one i would just want to broaden
it a little bit
and maybe pick up on the international
collaboration question you passed on to
betsy
in parts of the world where we are sad
one of the lessons for us
during covet was the following as soon
as the pandemic hit
we couldn't buy ppes because countries
stopped exporting them there were rules
that said you can't export
you couldn't buy therapeutics because
countries were stopping people
their companies from exporting it you
can't buy vaccines
and we realized in the developing world
we were at the mercy of the generosity
of others
and the international the who and other
systems
gavi kovacs while well-meaning
had limited ability to make a difference
in what i just described
so it became very clear to us very
quickly we are going to have to build
local capacity
to be able in research in in
therapeutics in understanding treatments
that work locally but that autonomy that
independence
from or the reliance or the lack of
reliance
from other uh international players was
something that came
hit home really hard and this is
something we are thinking about and it
will shape
what this university our universities
and other universities in
parts of the world where we are what
they decide to do and where they decide
to put their focus
as we go forward as far as the
issue of as you said going to online
learning
in countries where there is a challenge
of the availability of the internet
we pivoted very quickly we were very
fortunate we started a teaching and
learning center or a
a network very early that started to
look at
hybrid learning blended learning
asynchronous learning
because of the sheer number of countries
we were in
and the dispersion of our student body
and and faculty for that matter
so we we had already started to train
our faculty in thinking about this but
when the pandemic hit it was a
very sudden i think peter used the word
nimble
agile would be other the other word we
had to be extremely agile
to switch and start teaching our faculty
about
creating materials that they were using
for face-to-face teaching
for online learning and the population
of students
didn't know how to learn online they'd
never done it before so we're not only
here to train the faculty we had to
train the students
and the students many of whom were
removed either had limited internet
access or intermittent
and the one thing that in the west we
take for granted
that we don't have in our parts of the
world is power we didn't have
electricity
so why we said to the students you need
to go home and we'll you know you'll
learn from home
and there was no there was intermittent
electricity so
all of these challenges are continue for
us
and within that we are trying to make
this work now
um we were able to give devices because
of donations and generosity of people
to our students so they could actually
have a device like a notepad or a
computer
from which through which they could
access and that was
as basic as that we had to deal with but
i'm happy to say that when you look at
the results
of our students after 14 months although
they didn't you know the the
academic year was longer because we had
to stop
we are encouraged by the the results
that we see although peter's point is
very important
it's not the same we are seeing that the
experience is not the same
of people who are learning online versus
in a
with among classmates among others among
faculty and so that is something we are
trying to figure out how we can create
that environment
so people feel that the experiential
learning is an equally important part of
content that we see that comes through
online learning
we have another question from from the
audience uh
and and it's about teaching and learning
centers and
peter phuvu center at yale uh played a
hugely important role
in sustaining our activities our quality
of education etc but
going forward and thinking building on
our experience and
this question comes from professor
tashmin
thomas who is a leader in curriculum
development and quality in teaching etc
outside yale and
and so so what lessons can
we share in terms of the value of
teaching and learning
centers not just in pandemics etc but
beyond that
as well sure uh
we have a wonderful teaching and
learning center at yale called the porvu
center
and uh in a matter of
two-week spring break last march
they offered classes
small group workshops and one-on-one
tutorials
to essentially all the faculty teaching
uh especially young college students
[Music]
and getting them comfortable with zoom
and teaching on technology
we weren't optimizing at that point
we're just trying to help people make
the transition
uh quickly but what has happened over
time
as both people um have become more
comfortable
is a lot of creativity around teaching
online and again you know these teaching
and learning centers can be a source of
best practice
uh around uh collecting these um
uh innovations so i have a brother who
teaches
theater he teaches acting online and he
said well i teach acting for the stage
but actually zoom lets me talk a little
bit about what happens when you're in
front of a camera
and television acting film acting right
so he adopted he
changed my wife teaches um maternal and
child health
actually at uh uh state uh
uh university uh here in our region
and uh uh there you know she had the
challenges
of students who didn't all have
broadband
students all didn't have easy
and comfortable and isolating learning
environments
and learned to
change her classroom teaching in a way
that kept them involved
created more active learning so that the
the um
uh passivity of not having your
classmates around you or the lack of
social facilitation
uh didn't weigh too heavily so our
teaching and learning centers can be
wonderful repositories of collecting
knowledge about what works
and and what doesn't and then uh be a
great resource for our faculty
just one more point um
while teaching online teaching through
zoom teaching remotely
in my view will never replace
classroom instruction uh while places
like yale and places like vassar will
continue to be oriented around in-person
instruction primarily boy do they create
leverage for all of us
boy do they create the potential for
greater reach
i'm a psychologist and there's an
expression that psychologists like to
use came from a president of the
american psychological association which
is
how do we give psychology away
well i think a lot about how do we give
without without compromising our mission
without
compromising our financial health how do
we
give more of yale away
and we can give more of yell away
through you know the magic of zoom
uh and uh and
and we do and will just in the kinds of
situations that furrows
mentioned just one other quick thought
how are we all going to do our work
differently now that we have become
now that we as administrators have
become more comfortable on
on zoom is my carbon footprint going to
be as
large with all the traveling that
university presidents do
uh traditionally uh is it going to be as
large as it once was
when i can get together with feroz and
betsy for a meeting
you know on zoom without uh uh driving
to poughkeepsie or flying
to pakistan or kenya or where have you
right
i think we're all gonna i think we're
gonna do business in a lot of different
ways and our teaching and learning
centers
are gonna are gonna be the one of the
places that
picks up on helping us figure that out
not part of their traditional mission
but they're gonna help us uh figure out
when it works
when it doesn't so
a couple of sort of last brief questions
from the audience uh
starting with betsy i think there was a
very interesting and thought-provoking
question about
physical challenges in accessing
healthcare
and what institutions have learned in
this
crisis situation um you know
about people helping people with that
have trouble accessing
their surrounding communities uh et
cetera
in the healthcare setting but you have
thought about and worked on these kinds
of issues for a while
i think it's incredibly interesting and
important and unexpected
that for us the pandemic made all of us
unable to access what we used to be able
to access so easily
and in a way i think it really leveled
in some ways
leveled some playing fields around the
campus um
you know there wasn't walking a lot of
classes could be online people could
could access that better closed caption
on everything
um you know we worked on see through
masks so people who couldn't hear could
see the lips still
and it was it has been sort of an
amazing experience because i think um
now everybody understands better what
disability could be and what it could in
fact
result in in your life as a result we
just started a very high level committee
on
accessibility and are starting to put
together a much
different approach of how do we make our
environment
accessible for everybody and i i never
would have thought the pandemic did this
but again it brought a sort of we
precedes me approach it made us i think
more
understanding of each other and our
different abilities
so i'm hopeful for the future on this so
ferrous i'll give you the last
brief question which is you know what is
the future of international collaborator
collaborations uh for this pandemic
which is not nearly over in many parts
of the world
it's not over in any part of the world
but it will it is likely to go on longer
in many parts of the world
and and beyond what is the future of
collaboration
i think the pandemic has shown us that
this is not a local situation
something that happens in one part of
the world now gets
travels very quickly to another and
that's become pretty obvious to the i
think everybody involved
i think universities have a very
important role to play
uh in terms of bringing together uh
people to start to address some of these
problems
uh which are now common uh we all we
that's what we have seen
i don't think our governments have set a
good example as i said earlier
so far and so i think we need to work uh
beyond what the governments do not
within and or wait for leadership from
the governments because they have other
priorities they have other
constituencies that they have to satisfy
but i think there is an even more
opportunity now
for collaborations on vaccines on new
medications
on treatments and in some ways the
pandemic has leveled the playing field
that you use the expression that betsy
just described
we we've been done we have done clinical
undertaking clinical trials
in pakistan and kenya on chinese
vaccines on
on other vaccines french vaccines and so
on
and we've contributed to to the the data
on phase three trials and understanding
of certain populations or
certain ethnic groups and so that's
certainly been part of our contribution
and no reason
why we can't also uh work with other
institutions
in in developing common standards common
solutions
uh and common uh areas joint research is
beginning to flow
and the bill and melinda gates
foundation has been very strong in
supporting this and we're
uh we're recipients of their grants and
we're very grateful for some of the work
that they support
but we're not the only ones and working
with the
university of michigan or university of
washington or doing work in these areas
i think
we begin to demonstrate uh how much more
it's possible
yeah and yale and yale
i should just say while i have a minute
that our first collaboration was with
the yale i don't know the hospital the
new haven hospital
when we started they were describing to
us how they were dealing with this
because we were 60 days
after in terms of our surge that
happened
in in new haven and they really helped
us understanding
there was one thing they couldn't help
us with because they were they gave us
the idea you need to give bonuses to
healthcare workers
because because of the extra mile they
went right they were dealing with
coveted situations
and so on and we had to explain to them
that we asked our nurses to take a
a cut in salary so we could give the
institution afloat
so everywhere else we were able to learn
from them but i think they were
surprised
of the commitment of our people and the
mission that they actually took cuts in
compensation
to be able to address the challenges
that faced us so
yes including yeah yeah so so i'll just
wrap our a really nice and thoughtful
session
um with with a few words uh first
uh to say that we have the next event
with
dr ted rose from who uh that is coming
up that's the next event in the
conversation series
uh and then as we leave i think they
will uh sort of
project the slide uh so so uh i would
invite everyone to connect there and
it's shaping up nicely
based on our discussion with his team
and his staff uh and it should be
an interesting session um but i will the
last
thing i would say is that universities
have a unique role
in combating uh and preparing the world
for um mass challenges
like pandemics because pandemics often
happen across generations
and so uni you know universities
survive corporations they survive
governments and sometimes they survive
republics just as an example the top
eight corporations
uh in the u.s um have um
their life is uh you know the average
lifespan of the current topic
is approximately 60 60 years and ivy
league the eight ivy leagues
have um a uh
on average i think uh close to 275 years
old
and so therefore there's a unique
responsibility
on universities and their faculty and
their students to learn the lessons from
these
kinds of catastrophic events and pass on
to the next generation
through our research our teaching and
sharing how we
advise governments how we handle these
situations both as institutions
ourselves
but also as um the incubators
of some of the the best expertise
available
uh for addressing these problems uh so
so to to our students
no pressure uh but to our faculty that
it's a unique responsibility
i hope we will live up to going forward
uh for generations so so thank you for
to the panelists
uh thank you for the uh the engaged uh
audience uh we got a ton of questions i
couldn't
get to um all of them actually not even
half of them
but but but i really appreciate
everyone's participation
thank you assad thank you thank you very
much
nice to see everyone bye bye bye